Marie agnesstrack Zimmermann ist
FDP-Politikerin und Vorsitzende des
Verteidigungsausschusses im Deutschen
Bundestag herzlich Willkommen zu Phoenix
persönlich vielen Dank für die Einladung
Frau Zimmermann sie haben ja sozusagen
quaamt hauptsächlich mit militärischen
Fragen zu tun vor allen Dingen im Moment
was hören Sie zurzeit aus der Ukraine
wie ist der Standort
dramatisch ich hatte Gelegenheit vor 14
Tagen für einige Tage in die Ukraine zu
reisen und hatte vor allen Dingen
Gelegenheit auch einen Tag mit Soldaten
zusammen unterwegs zu sein wir sind nach
Norden gefahren von Kiew an die
belarussische Grenze und wenn sie damit
jungen Soldaten ins Gespräch kommen und
sie sind wirklich jung wie das ja leider
immer so ist dann zeigt es wie bewegt
alle sind wie kämpferisch wie groß der
Wille ist aber wenn sie hinter die
Fassaden kaufen schauen natürlich dieser
sehnliche Wunsch nach Frieden und diese
Fassungslosigkeit dass das was keiner
für Möglichkeiten hat dass dieses Land
von Russland überfallen wurde das kommt
im Gespräch eben immer wieder zur
Sprache was bedeutet das ihrer Meinung
nach das Putin vor zwei Tagen für die
von ihm annektierten Gebiete jetzt auch
noch das Kriegsrecht verhängt hat ja das
ist ja das ist ja ich wenn ich das mal
so sagen darf Tralala weil Putin hat
dieses Land überfallen am 24 februar und
ob er nun sagt das ist eine militärische
Aktion oder eine Sonderaktion oder
letztendlich wieder die Ukraine
vernichten und zwar die ganze Ukraine er
will dass sie von der Landkarte
verschwindet er will dass sie Teil
seines russischen Reiches wird und
deswegen sind jetzt diese Fingerübungen
seinerseits ja nur dazu da um uns den
Westen die Ukraine zu irritieren das
spielt alles keine Rolle er ist ein
Massenmörder ist ein Terrorist und der
terrorisiert die zivile Bevölkerung und
losgelöst von dem was er da versucht
einzubetten in diesem Zusammenhang ist
vermutlich auch zu sehen dass jetzt
immer mehr Energiequellen ja auch für
die Ukraine vernichtet werden das heißt
oder es wird vermutet seine Strategie
sei noch mehr Flüchtlinge in die
europäischen Nachbarländer dadurch zu
drücken geradezu weil die Verhältnisse
immer schwieriger werden jetzt haben wir
Meldungen dass er droht allen großen
Staudamm zu sprengen halten Sie das für
realistisch konnten sie sich das
vorstellen
wissen sie vorstellen kann man sich
überhaupt nichts wir leben im Jahre 2022
und nicht 1922 das in dieser Zeit wo
Grenzen nicht mehr verschiebbar sind wo
die UN auch dafür gesorgt hat nach dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg ist das Ganze surreal
ihm ist alles zuzutrauen das ist gar
keine Frage aber nichtsdestotrotz
sollten wir oder gerade deswegen die
Ukraine mit allem was wir haben
unterstützens betrifft ganz Europa
betrifft die Nato und diese Geschichten
die er erzählt dieses narrativ wo das
Bedrohungsszenario immer größer wird
zeigt ja seine militärische Schwäche er
hat geglaubt in zwei Wochen ist der
Drops gelutscht selensky ist weg die
Regierung ist weg
und er nimmt die Ukraine einfach Heim in
sein Reich und das funktioniert eben
alles nicht und deswegen wird jetzt auch
verbal natürlich aufgerüstet seine
Brutalitäten im zu sie sagten es gerade
wenn man den Menschen Wärme nimmt Wasser
nimmt dann setzt man sie massiv unter
Druck auch die Bombardements mit
japanischen Drohnen in im ganzen Land
also nicht nur an der Front sondern
sozusagen auch Ukraine ist ja ein
riesiges Land ganz im Westen jeder in
der Ukraine muss wissen es kann
plötzlich passieren und diesen
psycho-druck das nutzt der und darüber
hinaus sie sagten es gerade das nicht
der weißen ausgeführt werden kann so wie
er ausgeführt werden sollte in
Friedenszeiten fünf Millionen Tonnen im
Monat jetzt vielleicht ein Drittel davon
davon sind 190 Millionen Menschen
betroffen auf dieser Erde das heißt da
wird Druck ausgeübt dass wie sie gerade
sagten Migrationsdruck wo gehen die
Menschen hin wenn sie nicht mehr
überleben können Richtung Europa
Energie Frage wo gehen die Menschen hin
Richtung Europa genau das ist das was er
erreichen will uns den Westen die freie
Welt von innen aufzulösen und da müssen
wir jetzt an der Seite der Ukraine ganz
hart dagegenhalten sie sagten gerade es
ist ihm alles zuzutrauen natürlich wird
immer mehr und mit wachsender Sorge das
Wort Atomschlag von vielen Seiten
diskutiert und auch überlegt wie
realistisch das sein könnte wie schätzen
Sie das persönlich ein das ist natürlich
immer sehr kühne persönliche
Einschätzung zu haben weil ich abends
ins Bett gehe und natürlich genauso wie
alle Menschen in Deutschland und Europa
hoffen dass er es nicht macht ich halte
es für relativ unwahrscheinlich Wladimir
Putin würde ein Tabu brechen was nicht
nur in Europa Entsetzen auslesen würde
auslösen würde sondern in der ganzen
Welt auch in Ländern wie China die nicht
kein freies Land sind und
da spielt China schon eine große Rolle
weil es kann nicht im Interesse von
China sein das Despoten wie Putin die
Atombombe nutzen in der Nachbarschaft
von China ist Nordkorea übrigens auch
die Inder sind hoch alarmiert in der
Nachbarschaft von Indien sind die
Pakistani die eine Atombombe haben das
heißt die ganze Welt ist daran
interessiert dass eine Atombombe eine
Abschreckungsmittel ist aber zum Einsatz
kommen darf und insofern glaube ich dass
er das nicht machen wird und Sie merken
ja auch an den Worten dass er jetzt ein
Staudamm sprengen will dass er immer
noch mal so Stufen vorsetzt an
Grausamkeiten um eben uns alle ja in
große Angst und Schrecken zu
setzen und wir müssen aufpassen dass wir
dieses narrativ von ihm nicht selber
weiter transportieren sie waren ja nun
vor zwei Wochen schon zum zweiten Mal in
der Ukraine und haben dort die Menschen
besucht und natürlich auch die Politiker
wenn sie sich dort aufhalten wenn sie
dort sind sie sprachen mit Soldaten und
Soldaten sicherlich auch mit vielen
Menschen auf der Straße wie sehr geht
ihnen das nach
also was mir nachgeht ich versuche sehr
nüchtern daran zu gehen weil es ja
keinen Sinn hat wenn man Entscheidungen
zu treffen hat dass man zu emotional
wird aber ich bin ja hingefahren um eben
vor Ort mir einen Eindruck zu machen und
ich war ja noch nicht mal in der
Ostukraine also unmittelbar an der Front
was mir nachgeht ist wenn sie mit
Soldaten sprechen dann sind sie sehr
taff sehr tapfer und sagen wir werden
gewinnen wir werden Putin zurückdrängen
wenn sie dann mit Frauen sprechen ich
habe auch Kolleginnen aus der Rader
getroffen also aus dem ukrainischen
Parlament junge Frauen im Alter meiner
Kinder Anfang Mitte 30 die zum Teil
kleine Kinder haben
unglaublich politisch engagiert sind die
sind deutlich offener wenn es darum geht
darüber zu berichten wie viele
Ukraine Ukraine und auch wie viele
Soldaten in der Ostukraine sterben und
wie martialisch das dazugeht die sind so
unglaublich kampfbereit aber sie lassen
sie lassen mir zu dass man hinter die
anguckt das berührt mich schon denn wie
gesagt es sind könnten meine Töchter
sein meine Enkelkinder sein und das ist
einfach entsetzlich zu sehen dass sowas
in Europa überhaupt möglich ist sie
fordern ja selbst immer wieder sehr
vehement mehr militärische Ausrüstung
für die Ukraine wir haben mit diesen
Tagen vielen Dank gehört für dieses
Abwehrsystem das Deutschland geliefert
hat aber sie persönlich sind der Meinung
es müssten doch relativ schnell wirklich
Kampfpanzer dort hingeliefert werden es
macht den Eindruck nach wie vor als ob
der Bundeskanzler da nicht so ganz auf
ihrer Linie ist beginnt er da weiter vor
oder wie gehen Sie damit um sehr schön
ausgedrückt ich würde sagen nicht auf
nicht ganz auf meiner Linie ist noch
untertrieben er will es nicht man muss
an der Stelle sagen dass wenn man einem
Land hilft wie wir der Ukraine ist das
ja ein Tableau von Möglichkeiten also
was Deutschland macht ist inzwischen
auch anfänglichen absurden Diskussionen
dass wir wirklich sehr viel Material
schicken
Hightech Material wie die Iris t aber
hat eben wirklich auch schwere Waffen
wie die Panzerhaubitze wie der
Flakpanzer Gebhardt wie Mars ist ein
artillerie-system das tun wir und wir
liefern noch mehr nämlich
militärische Material also Kleidung für
den Winter
also viele Dinge die man braucht
losgelöst von lethalen Waffen das mit
den Panzern ist so relevant und darum
bittet man uns auch wirklich dringend
weil wir haben die Ukraine ist auch im
Süden wird auch vom Süden aus
angegriffen und das ist das ganze Gebiet
wo der Weizen angebaut ist wo sich
Flächen haben bis zum Horizont und sich
dort zu schützen ist noch mal was
anderes als wenn sie sozusagen Wälder im
Nacken haben und da wäre zum Beispiel
der der Marder ein Panzer der es möglich
machen würde eben russische Stellungen
zu bekämpfen und es ist fatal dass wir
das nicht liefern und die Argumente ich
höre ja durchaus zu meine Kollegen und
ich hören zu warum man das nicht jetzt
nicht so dass wir hier völlig verstört
durch Berlin Rennen und es gibt kein
Argument das heißt es werden immer
wieder Argumente gebracht die können wir
jetzt alle mal abhaken sondern es wäre
genau das richtige Zeichen 50 Marder
schützenpanzermarder jetzt und sofort
dorthin zu liefern damit die Ukraine das
sofort einsetzen können weil durch
diesen Ringtausch also das sowjetische
Material was andere Länder geschickt
haben das ist gut aber nicht im
entferntesten das was die Ukraine
braucht und deswegen sind wir da so
vehemente hinterher ich spreche jetzt
für die Freien Demokraten natürlich
nicht für den gesamten Ausschuss
und wir werden auch nicht nachlassen das
zu machen denn wenn wir nicht so strikt
seit Februar dran wären zu fordern wäre
das was wir heute machen nicht möglich
also es werden jetzt Dinge geliefert die
haben wir schon im März darum gebeten
geschützte Fahrzeuge dass die Ukraine
ihre Soldaten an die Front bringen
können geschützt und verwundete zurück
transportieren können wissen sie sind
damit offenen Autos unterwegs es ist ja
alles irre also mein Appell nicht nur an
den Bundeskanzler sondern auch an seine
ich sag mal an die Traube um ihn herum
an den Kanzleramtsminister an seinen
Berater wirklich da aktiv zu werden die
Zeit drängt sterben jeden Tag Menschen
das die sitzen nicht so wie wir im
Warmen und wissen dass sie heute gesund
bleiben das heißt das Modell steht da
draußen hüllt den Stein sie sie kämpfen
weiter ich weiß dass das nervt und ich
weiß es natürlich auch Menschen die uns
vielleicht heute zu sehen sagen mein
Gott die Strack Zimmermann immer mit
ihren Waffen wissen Sie ich habe selber
Kinder Schwiegerkinder Enkelkinder das
ist nicht schön jeden Tag sich damit zu
beschäftigen aber ich bin im
Verteidigungsausschuss unserer Aufgabe
dort ist es sich mit der Bundeswehr zu
beschäftigen dass unser Deutschland
eingebettet in Europa eingebettet in der
NATO werfähig und auch wer willig ist
und dazu gehören nun mal Waffen so wie
sie froh sind wenn so Gott Vermögen
verhindern möge sie überfallen und die
Polizei kommt und sagt zu ihnen ich
würde Ihnen ja gerne helfen aber leider
habe ich keine Pistolen und wenn ich
Pistolen habe keine Munition da würden
Sie sagen wenn ich bin hier im falschen
Film das ist unsere Aufgabe und
ja steht da tropfenhüllt den Stein aus
tiefer Überzeugung dass dieser Konflikt
nur militärisch gelöst werden kann weil
Wladimir Putin wird zu ernsthaften
Gesprächen nur gezwungen werden können
wenn er merkt dass er militärisch keine
Option hat nun haben wir ja neben den
Waffen inzwischen auch viele andere
Formen von Kriegsführung die mehr und
mehr in den Fokus geraten wir wissen
immer noch nicht woher die Sabotage
kommt an den Leitungen von aus dem 1 und
2 wir haben vor zwei Wochen erlebt dass
im gesamten Norden Deutschlands alle
Züge lahmgelegt wurden
selbstverständlich wissen wir noch nicht
wer es war es wird aber immer mehr für
möglich gehalten das russische Kräfte
beispielsweise auf diese Art und Weise
auch versuchen Einfluss zu nehmen wie
gehen Sie damit um war das schon immer
in ihrem Fokus sind das Dinge mit denen
wir uns jetzt einfach mehr beschäftigen
müssen haben wir da was verschlafen also
das mit dem mit der mit dem Angriff auf
die Bahn ich möchte jetzt nicht zynisch
werden aber wer viel mit dem Zug reist
weiß dass die Deutschen nicht in Unruhe
versetzt werden wenn man drei Stunden
kein Zug kommt aber Spaß beiseite wir
sind ein freies und ein offenes Land und
insofern sind wir natürlich angreifbar
das ist ja nicht nur die Infrastruktur
der Züge das ist viel Infrastruktur das
ist die Kommunikation das sind unsere
Satelliten das ist die die Infrastruktur
auf dem Meeresgrund nicht nur was
Energie betrifft sondern auch was was
Elektrizität betrifft und so weiter da
sind wir anfällig das war in
Sicherheitskreisen immer ein Thema wir
sind ein Hochtechnologieland aber wir
müssen uns oder wir nehmen jetzt erst
wahr wie volatilie an der Stelle sind
und auch die Bundeswehr die Marine zum
Beispiel wird sich deutlich mehr auch
mit dem Thema Unterwasser beschäftigen
müssen
als sie das in den letzten Jahren getan
hat mit jeder Herausforderung wird
natürlich die das gefahrenszenario
größer und wenn sie mich so Fragen mit
all den Gefahren die wir haben dass wir
angegriffen werden können dass es wieder
Panzerschlachten gibt das hat
Deutschland komplett ausgeblendet wir
haben uns vorgestellt es gibt Hybride
Angriffe also Terror wo man nicht so
genau weiß woher wir haben uns wir
wissen dass wir massiv Cyber angegriffen
werden jedes Unternehmen die
Bundesregierung auch Sie als Sender dass
das ist ein Thema aber dieses diese
diese
rustikalen herben Kriege die war nicht
mehr auf unserem Schirm und jetzt Leben
erleben wir eben die Hybriden Angriffe
auf die Infrastruktur damit müssen wir
lernen umzugehen und deswegen werden wir
unsere Sicherheitsstruktur neu aufbauen
müssen und das kostet viel Geld auch das
gehört zur Wahrheit dazu weil das Geld
ist man kann es nicht doppelt ausgeben
wir wir möchten dass das Geld unmittel
unserem Bürger ankommt aber es gehört
zur Wahrheit dazu sie müssen das Haus
erst mal schützen vor äußeren Einbrüchen
bevor sie die Inneneinrichtung der
Inneneinrichtung nachgehen und die
äußere Sicherheit Deutschlands wurde
über Jahrzehnte ich würde mal sagen nach
1990 Fall der Mauer Friede Freude
Eierkuchen jeder dachte jetzt beginnt
das Paradies und wir wissen heute 32
Jahre später das mit dem Paradies das
wird auf uns warten müssen und dass wir
ganz ganz ganz viel zu tun haben lassen
sie uns auf die Unterstützung der
westlichen Partner auch schauen für die
Ukraine da ist es bislang ja so gewesen
dass die USA ganz weit vorne waren Joe
Biden immer gesagt hat dass es nicht zu
diskutieren natürlich stehen wir an der
Seite der Ukraine wir haben wahnsinnig
viel Waffen geschickt wahnsinnig viel
Geld reingesteckt nun kommen die Mütter
elections auf die USA zu 8.9 november in
der Nacht und
es könnte durchaus sein dass die
Republikaner die Mehrheit im Kongress
zurückgewinnen nun gab es in den letzten
Tagen Verbesserung die doch hellhörig
gemacht hat eines führenden
Republikaners der gesagt hat wenn wir
die Macht zurückbekommen im Kongress ist
die Zeit der Blankoschecks vorbei für
die Ukraine ich zitiere das nur so im
Ungefähren und wir müssen wieder zu
diesem Denken Amerika first zurückgehen
macht ihnen das Sorge
naja ich mache mir mehr offen gestanden
gerade mal Sorge was in der
Bundesregierung zum Teil entschieden
wird aber natürlich schauen wir auf
unsere Partner und ohne die Vereinigten
Staaten wäre wäre die Ukraine mit
Sicherheit nicht so wehrfähig wie sie es
ist weil die Amerikaner gemeinsam mit
den Europäern unglaublich viel tun
bisher waren die Republikaner und
Demokraten an der Stelle was die
Leistungen betrifft sind an einem Strang
gezogen ja natürlich muss man da
hinhören und natürlich das wissen wir
auch vor dem Überfall Russlands auf die
Ukraine haben die Amerikaner überwiegend
nach auf den indupazifik geschaut das
Thema China wäre eine andere Sendung
wert darüber zu sprechen kommen wir
nachher auch noch rund natürlich sagen
die Amerikaner auch jetzt liebe Europäer
es ist euer Vorhof ich darf das mal so
sagen der Sicherheit wir sind Tausende
von Kilometern Weg wir schauen in den
Indopazifik ihr müsst euch um Europa
kümmern das wissen wir eigentlich auch
und insofern können wir dankbar sein
dass die Amerikaner und so unterstützen
es lehrt uns aber auch das Europa
selbstständiger werden muss ihm als in
Partnerschaft zu den USA dass Europa
auch innerhalb der NATO wehrfähiger
werden muss dass wir in Europa deutlich
mehr zusammenarbeiten müssen und auch
den Amerikanern ein Stück der Arbeit
abzunehmen die sie für uns hier leisten
und Deutschlands Rolle wird dabei sein
auch eine Führungsrolle zu übernehmen
das haben manche noch nicht verstanden
es gibt Aussagen von Politikern an sehr
exponierter Stelle ja wir müssen da noch
ein bisschen üben und es kommt jetzt
alles so plötzlich also nach 77 Jahren
Frieden nach 77 Jahren Wohlstand in
Deutschland den wir den Alliierten zu
verdanken haben USA Großbritannien
Frankreich die uns das überhaupt
ermöglicht haben ist es jetzt mal Zeit
dass wir sagen ja wir übernehmen Führung
da kann man auch mal Fehler machen aber
die Erwartungshaltung der Amerikaner uns
gegenüber ist groß und ich muss Ihnen
sagen ich verstehe das dass die
erwartungs an uns gerichtet ist also wir
sollten
auf uns mal achten und nicht immer
schielen was woanders passiert ja dann
achten wir jetzt mal auf uns und schauen
mal auf Europa da kriselt es neuerdings
ja zwischen Deutschland und Frankreich
ein wenig wegen der gaspreisbremse wir
hatten es gerade auf dem EU-Gipfel in
Brüssel wir haben in Italien einen neue
rechtsgerichtete Regierung mit einem
Silber Berlusconi der in
Regierungsverantwortung kommen möchte
mit seiner Partei bzw den Außenminister
stellen möchte und der sich rühmt er sei
einer der fünf besten Freunde Wladimir
Putins wir gehen wir denn damit um ja
Susanne Partei hat ja richtig eine
Klatsche bekommen und das ist ja eine
bizarre Persönlichkeit darf ich das mal
diplomatisch so ausrichten naja das ja
in enger Freund von Putin ist das ist so
diese Macho Kiste der würde sich
wahrscheinlich auch gerne mit Blanca
Brust auf ein Pferd setzen und gemeinsam
mit Putin reiten mal abgesehen von den
ästhetischen erschrecken den wir dann
erleben durften würde ich das mal
einordnen als ja auf dicke Hose machen
wie ich im Rheinland sagen würde
das ist alles nicht schön aber wir
werden natürlich schauen wie die
italienische Regierung ist
und da spielt er eine Rolle ob er
wirklich Außenminister wird
vielleicht sollten wir danach noch mal
sprechen ich möchte da nicht vorgreifen
ich glaube dass manchmal die Politik
dann doch pragmatischer ist und das
kennen wir ja durchaus auch im Vorfeld
unserer Wahlen das sehr rustikal
aufgetreten wird um zu zeigen was für
ein kerniger kerlmann ist und wenn man
dann in der Regierung ankommt und die
Realität einem vor Augen geführt wird
man vielleicht doch etwas auch verbal
abrüstet also sie sehen die Hoffnung
stirbt zuletzt
hoffen genau so machen wir es lassen Sie
uns auf den Iran schauen dort gab es in
den letzten Tagen vermehrt berichtet
darüber dass kampfdrohen iranische
Kampfdrohnen auch von den Russen
eingesetzt werden in der Ukraine was
haben Sie darüber gehört also das
scheint sozusagen oder das ist so
darüber geht wird auch das wird auch
öffentlich berichtet dass auch iranische
Soldaten in der Ukraine sind bzw in
Russland sind um russische Soldaten
auszubilden damit sind sie Teil der
Kriegspartei
das ist erschreckend aber es zeigt dass
dieser schurkenstart Iran der seit 42
Jahren frauenknechtet sich an die Seite
eines anderen schurkenstaats begibt also
diese laison ist nicht überraschend aber
sie ist natürlich dramatisch und sie
zeigt dass auch der Blick des Westens
auf den Iran da war ja es gab Sanktionen
aber in der Deutlichkeit eben nicht
stattgefunden hat und das was wir im
Iran sehen ich glaube das ist von großer
Relevanz diese unglaublich mutigen
Frauen die als Zeichen der Unterdrückung
das Kopftuch vom Kopf reißen nach der
Revolution von 1979 auf die Straße gehen
und diese Mullahs überhaupt nicht damit
umgehen können dass da Frauen sich
wehren das ist ja in deren
eingeschränkten Blickfeld überhaupt
keine spielt eine Frau keine Rolle die
wird zu Hause weggepackt jetzt gehen
genau diese Frauen unterschiedlicher
Generation auf die Straße das ist so
vehement dass es wirklich das System
ändern könnte und in diesem Kontext
passt es dem Iran natürlich sehr die
Kräfte emotional wirtschaftlich Europas
zu binden um sich mit der mit Russland
auseinanderzusetzen an der Seite der
Ukraine und wie gesagt manchmal sind die
Antworten ganz einfach und unsere
Antworten sollten auch ganz einfach sein
deutlich mehr Sanktionen der Iran muss
klar sein dass es so nicht geht es
werden gerade Gespräche geführt was das
Thema
Atombombe betrifft auch da muss man sich
fragen kann man sich mit diesen Menschen
momentan an einen TÜV setzen die
Gespräche könnten ausgesetzt werden also
da erwarte ich auch von der
Bundesregierung eine ganz klare
Stellungnahme und die Frauen bitten uns
den Westen dass wir
deren Stimme sind damit es nicht
verloren geht
es kommt jetzt alles zusammen wladimir
Putin hat mit dem Angriff auf die
Ukraine die ganze Welt
wirklich ins Wanken gebracht und jetzt
ploppen eben Dinge auf die wir alle
gesehen haben aber die so ein bisschen
unter dem Radar geflogen sind nun ist es
aber so dass natürlich sie haben es
gerade eben schon geschildert im Iran
sterben junge Frauen auf den Straßen
werden umgebracht weil sie das kauf doch
nicht tragen ihre wollte es im vollen
Gange meine mein persönlicher Eindruck
ist
dass wir zu anderen Zeiten wenn wir
jetzt diesen Krieg nicht hätten in der
Ukraine ganz anders darauf reagiert
hätten und vielleicht auch schon viel
Schaffer darauf reagiert hätten so läuft
das immer so ein bisschen unterm Radar
wir sehen das in den Nachrichten es gibt
aber ab und zu eine Sendung aber wenn
man sich überlegt was diesen jungen
Menschen die da auf die Straßen gehen da
passiert und auch droht ist das nicht
ein viel deutlicheren Aufschrei auch in
Deutschland Wert und tun wir da genug
naja sie sind Journalistin sie wissen
die Sendezeit ist begrenzt es passiert
gerade so unglaublich in der Welt aber
auch in Deutschland also auch mit den
Folgen die das für uns hat Thema Energie
Thema Inflation das natürlich die
Sendezeit gar nicht reicht alle Krisen
sozusagen gleichwertig zu behandeln
obwohl sie gleichwerte werde ich
behandelt gehörten zumal ist sehr sehr
wichtig ist den Menschen in Deutschland
zu erklären dass wir vor großen
Herausforderungen stehen wir als Reiches
Deutschland so viel wie möglich
kompensieren gerade ist im Bundestag
über die 200 Milliarden Euro diskutiert
worden die wir als Regierung auf den Weg
bringen wollen um Unternehmen aber auch
private Haushalte zu stützen und wenn
Sie das Gesamtpaket nehmen ich glaube
dass die Aufnahmebereitschaft der
Menschen und das meine ich wirklich sehr
ernst auch an Grenzen stößt weil jeder
hat sein kleines Leben jeder möchte
durch dieses Leben so gut wie möglich
kommen und wenn natürlich die
Information
reinprasselt das überall die Welt in
Flammen steht ich glaube dass da auch
eine gewisse Sättigung ist und die Leute
sagen also
ich mache den Fernseher jetzt aus ich
kann nicht mehr ich mache jetzt Netflix
an und schaue mir irgendwie Liebesfilm
an ich brauche mal irgendwas für die
Seele es wird ich sag das unserer
Aufgabe sein für sie als Journalistin
für mich als Politikerin diese Themen in
den Vordergrund zu schieben sie
einzubetten zu erklären und den Menschen
zu erklären alles hängt mit allem
zusammen und wenn wir hier in Frieden
und Freiheit leben wollen auch unsere
Kinder und Enkelkinder müssen wir diesen
Despoten mit allem was wir haben
entgegenstehen und das ist nur mal
unsere wirtschaftliche Macht und das
müssen wir auch dem Iran klarmachen sie
haben jetzt gerade noch mal alle
multiple Krisen wie es so schön heißt
irgendwie noch mal Umrissen wenn wir in
dem Zusammenhang auf die
regierungsvorlesion schauen und auf die
Ampel
wir erleben Sie die Ampel da und es hat
nun jetzt ein Machtwort des Kanzlers
gebraucht letzte Woche mit
Richtlinienkompetenz um den akw-streit
zu beenden ist es nicht auch ein
schwierige Kombination man sagt immer
drei Jahr Konstellationen können
ausproblematisch sein wenn zwei sich
streiten freut sich der Dritte es geht
auch das Wort von drei ex-verhältnis mit
wechselnden Mehrheiten es gibt aber auch
Dreier Bündnis aber wir erleben sie das
denn im Grunde genommen sind einer ist
ja doch immer anderer Meinung ja das
stimmt so nicht ich muss Ihnen sagen ich
bin überrascht wie gut wir
zusammenarbeiten das mag bei dem ein
oder anderen Zuschauer jetzt ein Lächeln
hervorrufen aber die Arbeit findet ja in
den 25 Ausschüssen statt und auch in dem
Ausschuss dem ich Vorsitzender auf dem
Verteidigungsausschuss arbeiten die
demokratischen Parteien wirklich sehr
konstruktiv zusammen und die Ampel
allemal es ist natürlich so wir sind
zusammengekommen drei sehr
unterschiedliche Partner und haben den
Auftrag bekommen eine Regierung zu
bilden nachdem die CDU ja am Wahlabend
vor allen Dingen Herr Söder gesagt hat
vielen Dank das war's wir gehen jetzt in
die Opposition der arme Herr Laschet
konnte kein klaren Gedanken fassen man
hat in Bayern wo dann schon der Maßkrug
auf den Tisch gehauen da war der Drops
gelutscht so
wir haben verhandelt wir haben mit
respektvoll verhandelt es war am Anfang
so ein bisschen jetzt sitzen wir hier
zusammen am Tisch wir müssen jetzt was
draus machen das ist aber unser Job das
ist uns gelungen 80 Tage später bricht
ein Krieg aus in Europa ein Krieg den es
seit 77 Jahren nicht gegeben hat in
dieser Form Grenzverschiebung in jeder
Hinsicht
jede Regierung also wenn es noch eine
große Koalition wäre die große Koalition
hat sich die letzten Jahre mit Verlaub
phasenweise mit dem Gesäß nicht mehr
angeguckt die hätten die Diskussion
heute auch so wenn es Schwarz-Gelb oder
schwarz-grün-gräbe wenn wir heute einen
schwarzen Bundeskanzler hätten Herrn
Laschet oder wen auch immer
meinen Sie was dann auf der Straße los
wäre die Diskussion die wir führen über
Waffen dass wir Waffen liefern mit
Unterstützung der Grünen Partei das
hätten sie mir vorhin ja gesagt die
Grünen wollen das haben sie was geraucht
Frau Zimmermann ist aber so weil sie
pragmatisch sind das heißt wir gehen
alle ein pragmatischen Weg und dazu
gehört auch eine Diskussion das ist
einfach so und deswegen auf ihre Frage
zurückkommt das mag verstörend sein ja
da hat der Kanzler auf den Tisch gehauen
und hat gesagt jetzt machen was so ja
das ja wahrscheinlich war er genervt und
hat gesagt so jetzt machen wir das so im
Grunde sind alle zufrieden jetzt läuft
es und es wird vielleicht an der ein
oder anderen Stelle mal der eine mehr
mehr rausholen als der andere
Dreierkonstellation sind auch im
privaten Leben nicht
empfehlenswert also insofern wir haben
diesen Auftrag ich bin sehr zuverlässig
zuversichtlich auch dass das über die
nächste legis
halten kann weil wir wie gesagt deutlich
besser zusammenarbeiten natürlich ist in
der Öffentlichkeit immer die Diskussion
das interessante die 90 Prozent wo wir
einer Meinung sind ist natürlich nicht
so spannend und insofern glauben Sie mir
es läuft deutlich besser als mancher
glaubt trotzdem muss ich sie zum Schluss
noch auf das letzte Thema ansprechen wo
sich wahrscheinlich doch wieder ein
Essenz abzeichnet und zwar die
Investition der staatlichen chinesischen
Reederei die geplante von 35 Prozent in
den Hamburger Hafen die Grünen haben
schon erkennen lassen dass sie da
dagegen sind man geht davon aus dass
Olaf Scholz der ja Anfang November nach
China reisen wird
durchaus dafür sein könnte auch in
seiner alten traditionellen
Verpflichtung der Stadt Hamburg
gegenüber dies natürlich möchte auch die
SPD dort möchte dass
viele sagen dass es der nächste Eingriff
in die kritische Infrastruktur
Deutschlands der Chinesen wie ist die
Haltung der FDP also wir haben uns alle
sofort gemeldet wir werden das nicht
mittragen oder keinen Umständen es ist
gerade zu fatal wir haben diese wir
sehen die Abhängigkeit Energie Russlands
gegenüber wir wissen dass die Chinesen
weltweit wenn sie auf dem Balkan
unterwegs sind wenn sie Afrika unterwegs
sind übrigens auch in Deutschland wenn
Sie die helfen von Piräus von von
italienische Häfen sehen wie Triest
Genua die sind alle schon in chinesische
an das ist irre ist das mit Faller
entschuldigung wenn ich das so sage es
ist nicht nachvollziehbar und man kann
mir sagen das ist ja keine kritische
Interview das sind ja nur Terminals es
ist ein Unding das angesichts der
Erfahrung die wir jetzt gerade machen
und weiterhin weiterhin zulassen dass
das chinesische Imperium was
letztendlich nichts anderes will als den
Westen einzuschränken dass wir da uns
gewissermaßen derart anbieten völlig
ausgeschlossen der Kanzler muss das
wissen dass ein großer Fehler
und dass wir vehement dagegen sein
werden wenn er nach China reist kann er
den dortigen Kollegen ja ausrichten dass
der Westen das in Zukunft nicht weiter
mitmacht auch das ist die Lehre aus dem
was wir gerade erfahren wenn wir in
Europa und ich spreche wirklich von
Europa und nicht lösen bei aller
Freundschaft war allem Handel von diesen
Abhängigkeiten wir haben es in der
corona-krise gesehen wir waren nicht
mehr in der Lage relativ schnell Masken
herzustellen Desinfektionsmittel
Medikamente wenn wir uns nicht endlich
lösen
dann ich weiß nicht was noch passieren
muss damit die Berater des Kanzlers
vielleicht mal aufwachen also ich war
ich dachte ich lese nicht richtig also
inzwischen
aber ich war erleichtert zu sehen dass
auch die Kolleginnen und Kollegen genau
das so sehen und ich weiß auch wenn das
der Grünen ja ich weiß aber auch von
Sozialdemokraten die haben sich auch zu
Wort gemeldet da wird der Kanzler keine
Mehrheit für bekommen und bei allem
Respekt vor der Zuneigung zu einer Stadt
ich komme aus Düsseldorf ich durfte dort
Bürgermeister sein ich liebe Düsseldorf
aber ich würde
zulassen und wir haben schon genug
chinesisches Know-how da dass man jetzt
unter diesen Gesichtspunkten so
weitermacht als ob nichts passiert wäre
das ist ein völliges Unding und ich
hoffe dass das abgewandt werden kann
dann sind wir gespannt wer das nächste
machwort spricht oder erst zumindest
versucht prostaktionen vielen Dank für
das Gespräch ich danke Ihnen
[Musik]